[Music]
my name is Vic
Iglesias I'm a cloud solutions architect
and this is I'm in and I'm a developer
advocate I will based in Tokyo Japan so
today we're gonna kind of walk you
through how Google cloud platform
billing works as well as show you some
cool things you can do once you have the
data at your fingertips cool so let's
get started
so a lot of what happens in the cloud is
you need to do something you start a new
project you start hammering away using
new api's creating new data sets new
data bases new instances and you get
something working so that's great so now
you have something that works and you
often kind of build off of that at no
point did you really think what kind of
instances am i using what kind of
products am i using how are they build
so someone comes by the engineering team
and says hey so what what is the the
money you're spending for development
like well we don't know we just kind of
spent stuff up what do you what are you
doing to run in praat well you know the
bill kind of looks like this we think
8020 dev to prod but we're not really
sure so at some point you have to kind
of wrangle this back so today we're
gonna go through how billing works show
you how you can estimate for the future
show you how you can look at your past
spending how you can slice and dice your
bill so you can separate different
pieces of it and then how you can export
your data which is when things get
really interesting and then we'll show
you visualizing your bill using data
studio and that's where ian is gonna
blow your guys's minds so let's get
started so what is billing look like in
Google cloud platform first we'll start
with some terms we have projects and
projects are an isolation domain that
lets you place resources inside them so
every resource you create in Google
Cloud is within the context of a project
each project has a billing account
associated with it you can have many
projects associated with a single
billing account and the billing accounts
are sociated with some way for us to
charge you so this is kind of a
diagram of what it would look like to
have three projects and to billing
accounts at the at the top will show
that the funding sources so you have a
credit card that's associated to a
billing account or a bank account that's
associated to your billing account and
those generate invoices you can also do
offline billing which will invoice you
at the at the end of the month here you
can see that billing account one has two
projects associated with it and billing
account two only has one project so
that's kind of a high-level overview of
how billing is is architected in Google
Cloud cool so what if you are really you
know judicious about your cloud usage
and you actually want to know before you
start using something how to figure out
what it's gonna cost you well we have
our pricing calculator so you can enter
in all of the different products you
intend to use and this is often a hard
thing to do but you're kind of just
getting the shape of what your bill is
gonna look like and where you can save
some money if you don't or do or don't
use certain products so you can go ahead
and look at that pricing calculator it's
easy to find online what about going
back and looking at last month's bill so
that's pretty easy in our console we
have a billing overview breaks down line
items of different products shows you
how much usage you have for those
products and how much you were charged
you can also go back to past
transactions and past bills in the
console in the transaction view and has
a very similar outline of what you guys
have I get some credits every month to
use on Google cloud so you can see my
bill was negative which is kind of how
you want to keep it if you can and then
at some point you're gonna want to put
some guidelines in place to make sure
that the right people know that the
usage is getting either out of line or
staying in line so we have what are
called budgets and alerts so you can set
a budget and say this account or this
project should not go over this amount
of money in a month and then you can set
up percentages of that budget that you
want to be alerted on so at for example
50 percent 90 percent 100 percent you
may not necessarily take corrective
action but you can at least know that
it's happening right if if you get your
90 or 50 percent or your 90 percent
alert
on the third day of the month
something's probably off so you can go
check it out figure out what's going on
and then act on it now that you've seen
all your bills you can get a line item
of each product that was used within a
project what if you have multiple
environments that you have running
within a project right this is very
common where you have an environment
that's deaf you can use our labels which
are key value pairs in order to label
different resources in your project for
example I have some cloud storage
buckets and some compute instances and I
can label a subset of them with the
environment death I can also go ahead
and label my production VMs and storage
with the EM production so now when I
look at my bill
I can see these labels and be able to
partition my my spending into different
groups and since these are key value
pairs you can do whatever you need for
your organization that makes sense
this is where you get really powerful
features out of your cloud platform
billing when you start exporting billing
data and can use it in you know do your
data science or your machine learning or
whatever you need to do in order to get
some insights out of your bill so we
allowed you to export your billing data
straight into bigquery and we all know
and we've all heard how powerful big
theory is so you can export directly
into another project so you can choose a
project and a database that you want to
export your your bill to and you can
also export straight into GCS so just
get a CSV dumped and use your favorite
tool whatever that is obviously our
favorite tool is bigquery we recommend
it and we'll show how powerful that can
be in Ian's demo so what is what is the
demo going to look like
so we're gonna have a billing account
that's associated that has two projects
in it and we're gonna be sending both of
those projects billing data to a third
accounts bigquery database and from that
bigquery database we're gonna send our
data to data studio so that we can
create some nice dashboards right we
want to have an executive view of what
our bill looks like nobody wants to be
looking through
actionview at the executive level they
want to have something that they can
kind of glance at and say we're kind of
on track or be able to dig into a bill
really easily so we're gonna set up this
dashboard and IANS gonna take it away
and show you how it works
awesome well let's do that over to my PC
there we switch over to my PC yeah there
we go alright so here's a my my billing
account or this is the Google Cloud
console and so I have a my billing
account for this particular set of
projects and so while we're here we can
kind of take a look at some of the
different pages that that Vic talked
about so here we have the kind of
budgets and alerts field so you can kind
of say you know create budgets and give
it a name
over budget ok like this and then you
can specify an amount and you can
specify these in percentages as well
also if I remember right yes down here
you can spend said percentage of a
budget or an amount and you can actually
set these to over a hundred if you want
to as well in case you're really over
budget and you want to get alerts when
you're how far you're over budget as
well also you have these the
transactions page and right now this one
this particular one doesn't have any
transactions we get a nice nice graphic
here but this is which what I really
wanted to talk about today which is the
the export page so this is the the most
powerful part of the of billing so here
we have two options we have one to
export to Billy query and we can show
also this file export as well where we
can actually export JSON data every day
to Google Cloud storage and here we can
specify a bucket and a name report name
for our prefix and this will just get
prefixed to the file names
and then we can export that in CSV or
JSON and that's great but the the files
are not as easy to parse like it'll put
a new one in there every day so what we
want to do is export as bigquery or
export to bigquery and we can select the
project and the the data set the
bigquery data set and then just click
the enable bigquery export here so if we
do that it'll just start exporting to
bigquery and it's really as simple that
is that it's like inside that data set
it'll create a new table for you and in
that side of that table it will start
putting in the big four or in in that
table it will start putting the the
Behling transactions and it essentially
does this in you know not real time but
close to real time ie like maybe every
day or about every day so you can
essentially just query this table and
get the latest data about your
particular billing account so let's look
with that table look at what that table
looks like so over here in bigquery we
have this table so it comes as into our
our data set as a table that says UCP
billing export and then it's got some
extra characters after the end so if we
click this you can kind of see our table
and this is the the schema that we get
when our table is actually created so
here we can see our billing ID product
the product is the at the level of
something like a compute engine or App
Engine or pub/sub and then inside each
of those products we have a resource so
inside of compute engine we have things
like instances we have our VM instances
we have networking or network load
balancers we have persistent disks
those are end up being resources so you
can think of product and then resource
as a sub subtype and then we have a
start time and end time and essentially
inside of this table we're going to get
a new record for every transaction so
for every project and product or product
in
project and resource type we are going
to get a new entry in our table and that
start and end time is going to be at
most one day so you can you know that
Google cloud has per minute billing so
you could have an instance that runs for
only a few minutes and that will get
built but if you have it open for
multiple days you will get multiple
records for each day and then inside
here we've got our project and inside
that we get our project metadata like ID
name and labels for the project itself
and then here's the also the labels that
we get for all of the objects inside of
inside of GCP so this is the labels that
Vic mentioned where you can label things
like bigquery tables or your instances
with your tags to identify things like
production and development environments
or whatever you see see fit and those
get exposed here as part of the billing
data as well so you can then kind of
slice and dice your data based on that
and then here we have the kind of usual
things like cost and currency and the
amount of credit so those credits so
you'll see things in these credits like
sustained use discounts like so for VMs
these sustained use discounts will be
exported here in the billing as a credit
against your your billing account so
that's our table it's pretty
straightforward so if we go ahead here
and just kind of take a look at it we've
got a table here we could say like
select our project ID and then the sum
of our costs maybe cost and then go down
here and group by the project ID I
project ID then we go ahead and run that
this is just a simple query we can see
that we'll get our you know billing data
for our couple of projects so since I
started exporting billing data this
project has had about $7,000 billed
against it and this project has had
about $2,000 billed against didn't
so you can kind of do those type of
queries and you can think of any type of
query that you want to anything or you
can use the power of bigquery to
actually or to slice and dice your
billing data and kind of get insights
that well way so you can do these type
of ad hoc queries against the bigquery
table
that's not actually what what's
interesting about that we want to do
more more powerful things your finance
officers are and your finance folks are
not going to be writing SQL probably
every day to figure out your the costs
for your for your resources so what
they're going to do once has something
that's much more visual something more
like a dashboard and so that's what I
want to show you guys today so this is
actually the Google Data studio which is
a really easy way to create these kind
of dashboards right and kind of show
them to your finance officers and to
your to your finance folks and they can
kind of play with them and get an idea
of like of what the costs look like so
let's take a look at one of those and it
looks like I didn't actually create one
gonna have to figure this out on the fly
yeah so I guess we're gonna have to do a
lot let's see if you can do it life I I
have faith what do you guys think you
can get you guys a dashboard though so
we're gonna do this live so this is this
is good because we can kind of get a
sense of how easy it is to you to do
these kind of dashboards um and so also
we can kind of think of you know just to
get us in the mindset here let's imagine
we have like you are startup or
something and we've got our our finance
officer breathing down our neck he wants
our report in 20 minutes or something
like this so we we need to quickly put
together our report so the first thing
that you do when you create a new report
inside of data studio is you get a blank
page like this and then you're prompted
to add a new data source so here we can
click a new data source and then in here
there's a bunch of different data
sources but the one we care about is
bigquery so we'll click that
and then click our project name and our
data set and then we'll get our big
furry export table here and once we get
we've selected that we can hit click
connect and that will add it to or add
it to our report and what's really cool
is that
it's because bigquery is a table and it
knows the schema it comes into that
schema comes into our report so here
we've identified all the fields that are
available not data source and these
correspond to the fields in the table
right and then each of those has a type
and then we can use those to actually
create our reports so we don't actually
have to write any SQL and we'll see how
did how to create those reports in a
second but here we get a little prompt
we'll add that to our report you can
kind of review the data sources by
clicking on this resources section and
do managed the data manage data sources
and you can kind of see all of the ones
that are added to the report so there
we're only going to add one actually for
this one but now that we have a data
source let's go ahead and create a
little bit of chrome just to make this
look nice this add a header some nice
GCP blue and then we're gonna add an
image actually go here
we're not image our file go to the
desktop cuz you know I have these Google
cloud logos just hanging around my
desktop you got to make it look flashing
yeah you got to make this flashy you
know we want to wow our our finance
officer so we did that and then we'll
add a little title just to add our text
and well
this really big 8 and this in white
awesome dashboard right this is pretty
easy so far we just you know created a
little bit of chrome just to make it
look nice but this is where it gets
interesting we can start adding these
kind of graphs to our reports so first
let's just add a pie chart and see what
that looks like whoops go like this
once I add a pie chart a kind of data
studio will figure out like the the
fields from our data source and it will
kind of by default put in some some
values so right away you get some pretty
interesting reports and in this case
it's a little bit small to see but you
can actually see that this graph this
pie chart is showing us our our costs by
a byproduct here so here we see compute
engine and App Engine so this particular
billing account we have mostly compute
engine about 78% of our cluster at
compute engine and 28 20 percent of our
calls for App Engine but I don't want to
do it at quite at that level I wanted to
do it at a little bit more granular
level so what I'm going to do is change
the size a little bit here and then I'm
going to change the fields here the
dimension that I'm going to be using for
this particular report so instead I'm
gonna choose the resource type now if
you choose the resource type we get a
much more granular pie chart and this
guy is going to tell us that we are this
over here we can see based on the
resources so we can see this this is our
GCP instances or GCE instances this is
our our persistent disks so persistent
disks are about 16 percent of our costs
and then front-end instances are 11 and
data stores 9 and so on we'll go out
here back to the edit mode
with that over and then I'm what I'm
gonna do next is I'm gonna add a deep
filter and what these these do is allow
you to like have a date drop down
essentially into the report so this
makes the reports really interactive and
what you can do is when you're viewing
the report you can actually select a
date range and that will apply to all
the graphs within the report so you can
then not just create a report for like
this month you can create a report and
then have it interact and be interactive
and you can select the date ranges that
you want to have for that report so here
we'll select as a default date range and
this data set just happens to be from
December to February let's that and then
we'll add another filter here and this
is a filter control that is shown as a
as a table list this is actually a
little bit small to see but what this
does is allow you to filter by a
particular dimension as well so here
we've got it created by default of
product so we can kind of uncheck these
and and filter by products but what I
want to do is change the dimension here
to be the project ID so this particular
glowing account has two projects on it
and we can kind of see that in our our
filter and so if we go back we go back
here and look at it we can kind of see
that we've got two projects here and
then one more we're going to add a time
series and this time we're gonna make a
time series based on our cost so here's
our daily costs essentially over time
and then but what I'm going to do here
is I'm going to add a breakdown
dimension and this breakdown dimension
will actually add break all the costs
down over the particular dimension so
here I want to break costs down by
product
so I'm going to select the product field
when I do that that's going to break it
down by product so you'll see a little
align graph on this per product we can
see that we're overwhelmingly using two
products one of them is GC PGCE so the
compute engine and one is app engine you
can see the compute engine costs don't
really change over time because we have
the same amount of VMs running but app
engine kind of changes as the load comes
in you can see that over time and that's
that's how really helpful so that's like
so just in a few minutes you can kind of
get a really really neat graph that's
interactive and shows you a lot of
information let's actually make this a
little bit smaller so we can see the
whole thing and then it's actually
interactive here so we can do is we can
say you know view the the data over the
last 30 days or you know just for the
last week and you can do that by just
changing the date fields here and all of
the SQL queries are generated for you
and then applied to the graphs and we
can also do that here for these filters
here so we if we uncheck one of these it
will remove that particular one from our
project so here or from our our
dashboard so here we've unchecked the my
web app project and just the let left
the ji-ae app and so we can see that the
this particular project is using App
Engine and it's the costs are basically
just front-end instances and data store
real apps and if we go back the other
way we can see the other project is our
is a GC based project and so you can see
that that has is using things like GCE
instances persistent disk as well as as
load balancers and here we can see that
we've got Network load balancing
we've got other custom custom instance
types and then we've got other another
set of load balancers so the load
balancers are actually a fair fair bit
of our cost so maybe we could think
about ways to reduce that cost
later so this is the like a really neat
dashboard and basically you'll notice
that I didn't write any SQL query or SQL
queries against bigquery it just knew
the fields and it knew how to use the
fields based on matter types to generate
the queries for me and generate the
graphs I didn't have to do any of that
and that's great if we want to do
something that's you know relatively
simple but it's you know still powerful
but if we want to get really into our
data we can actually do things like
custom queries so here I'll hit the edit
mode again and data studio allows you to
create new multiple pages for your
reports so here I'm gonna add a new page
and in this new page I'm going to add a
few new graphs but these graphs are
going to be slightly different what I'm
going to do is I'm going to create a bar
graph but I'm going to populate this bar
graph with data from a custom query that
I write and so we'll see what that looks
like here so when I go here I can say
choose the data source for this
particular graph and what I'm going to
do is actually just create a new data
source and when I do that I can click
big query and instead of clicking on my
projects I can go down here to custom
query and then from there you choose a
project for it to the custom query to
run in and then you can just type your
query in here and I've got a query that
I've got written already pretty simple
query yeah this is you know anybody can
figure that stuff out yeah it's a pretty
nice one well if we have some time we'll
actually go we can actually go through
this but well the interesting thing is
what ian is gonna do here is basically
try to predict the future with bigquery
exactly so you can tell your CFO what
you think you're gonna spend later
without even having to use the pricing
calculator yeah let's see what kind of
magic you can come up with yeah so what
this is actually doing is it's over the
last three months of data it's actually
doing a linear regression over the last
three months of data and then we're
going to solve that linear regression
for the next couple months and what
that's going to do is predict the
current month and the next month's
billing data so we'll see what that
looks like here how many lines of code
was that in the query in this query this
one is 83 lines of code
that's not bad that's not bad when we
get out but we get out of this is we get
these three fields from the SQL query
and those fields get translated into the
fields that come into my report right so
data studio knows from the custom query
what the output fields are and then we
can use those output fields to generate
our report so here we have a future
balance in a balance field and I've kind
of separated those two but basically the
past months will be will have data in a
balance field and the future months will
have the data in the future months field
and I'll kind of show you why I did that
but it kind of has to do with the report
itself and then I'm just gonna add that
to my report as a data source and then
in here in the dimension I can select
from the data that came back from my
custom query so here I'm going to
collect select month as a as my
dimension and as my metric I'm going to
select balance here and so you can see
that I've created a bar graph for the
past three months of billing billing
data so these are my costs for the last
three months and so I'll go back and
what you can do is you can actually add
multiple metrics to a lot of these
graphs so what I'm gonna do here is add
another metric and this time I'm gonna
add the future balance so normally what
you would do in these cases is multiple
metrics would show up as bar graphs that
sit next to each other but because
they're these are kind of mutually
exclusive for each month they kind of
show up with big spaces in the middle so
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna do a
little bit of a heck with this is I'm
gonna change it to multiple colors and
then I'm gonna actually stack these and
since they don't stack they stack on
basically nothing they kind of look like
they're next to each other so this is a
little bit bit of a display hack but you
can see that I did that so that I can
put the past months in blue and the the
future months in red here and so this is
actually the current month in the next
month so I don't actually have billing
data for this but I'm actually
extrapolating from my past data what my
future data might look like so you can
see that my past data is trying to
trending down so we've extrapolated out
that the billing data will go down a
little bit over the next couple months
that's great we can kind of predict the
future a little bit and kind of see
maybe ease our our financial officers
Minds a little bit about how much we're
spending but the last graph that I want
to do here is what it really illustrates
the power of of using bigquery exporting
your billing data to bigquery because
bigquery can be you can put any types of
type of data into a bigquery table and
likely you already have a lot of
business data there which we can do is
actually combined our billing data with
data that we know about our application
in order to create much better and more
richer Ninni metrics so here what I'm
going to do is I'm going to create
another another data source using a
custom query and I'm going to use a
slightly less less complicated query
it's only 82 lines of code I know it's
actually only 17 lines I could have in
this line 11 but this one's actually a
really simple query and I'll go ahead
and connect that in but what I'm going
to do is since my application is a
that's interesting came with the wrong
fields there it ain't quite copy and
paste it properly there we go so what
I'm doing here is I my my application is
a web application right so I'm using
Google and Google Analytics and I have
Google Analytics premiums so I'm
actually exporting that data the
analytics data to bigquery so in this
case I'm I'm just using my analytics
data I'm gonna go ahead and apply this
to join that table during that analytics
table with my big free table and then
generate
essentially a cost per unique user and
so what I'm doing here is I get out a
couple of fields the date in the cost
per unique user so I'll add that to the
report and I'll show you the graph first
but then we can kind of look at what the
query is doing and I'll explain a little
bit what the about what the query is
doing whoops
one thing you can note is you know
despite all of our data sources here
coming from bigquery there are a bunch
of other sources you can use like just a
regular sheet if you've got a sheet with
a bunch of data that you need to merge
in with some bigquery you can do that as
well not everything has to be coming
from bigquery yeah right so so for a
single report you can only choose one
one single data source for inside of a
report you can have multiple graphs and
each one can come from different data
sources but for a single graph you need
to have only you can only associate one
data source so generally if you want to
combine multiple data sources into a
single graph then the best way to do
that is with multiple bigquery tables
and then joining them with a custom
query and that's exactly what I did here
so we'll take a look at what this with
this particular query is doing but what
we're doing here exactly is we're taking
our billing data and this is my my
billing table and then we're doing a
join on that to our Google Analytics
sessions table and when we do that we
can extract out the the distinct visitor
IDs so this essentially gives us a
unique user everyday yeah and we're
grouping that by date and then we join
that with the tables and then up at the
top here we're cut we're dividing the
cost by the unit number of unique users
to get the number of the cost per unique
user so we can kind of see how that goes
over time and we can see that some of we
have some spiky spiky days where our
cost per unique user goes up really high
so we can kind of investigate why that
might be and maybe X you know find out
why our application is like becoming
inefficient on those days
also combine things with not just like
Google Analytics data but say data that
happens to be coming from your your
application maybe you have log data
that's already created that you can join
it to or maybe you have some other type
of data about how many users you have or
the the lifetime the lifetime revenue
that you get from those users and you
can kind of compare that to how much
you're spending for your for your
resources in the cloud so this is like
very very proud phul to actually get a
get a much more holistic view about how
you're spending your resources not just
I'm spending my X number of dollars here
X number of dollars here but actually
per per user how much you're costing so
that in the future say if you have an
application that has 5000 users right
now but what happens if you have 10,000
users or a hundred thousand users in
those cases you can extrapolate how much
your application would cost as your as
your application scales into the future
and this is also really good because
like say if you are using multiple
clouds who happens to be using multiple
clouds GCP + Amazon so a lot of you
right
so one of those things that you could do
with this is say you know you get your
your billing data you export it to
billing you're GCP billing data you
export that to bigquery you get your you
know CSV dump from Amazon you put that
into bigquery cuz bigquery is awesome
and then you join those two or you put
those two together and you can kind of
look at your cost per user say for each
cloud so say you know GCP you know
versus you know another cloud what's the
cost per user per Eid for each of those
clouds right and you can see like as
your application scales up and gets more
users where like where you're actually
syncing those costs and where you're
actually the cost is more efficient so I
know that you guys don't want to you
know pay us more money but the way to be
have to kind of be happy there for
everyone to be happy maybe is for free
for everyone to kind of realize which
perhaps which clouds have the best cost
per user and kind of move those clouds
to or move those workloads to hopefully
to GCP yeah so what we've shown you
today is basically how to look at your
bill and pay us less money which is
totally great for us we want that to
happen I think you know all this power
and these specific queries are not
important as much as the conceptual
pieces that we've shown you the fact
that you can bring different data
sources in the fact that you can chop up
your bill in different ways and
especially that you can use data studio
to make really easy dashboards that you
can present a holistic view of your bill
and depending on what questions you're
being asked you can answer those really
easily with this studio so that's about
it for our presentation
[Music]
you